Salam alaikum hey guys how you doing I'm
gonna take a few minutes to comment on
these Christian women notice these are
Christian women in the church this video
is especially important to anyone who
has ever looked down upon a Muslim woman
wearing hijab who has ever had this hate
towards a Muslim woman because she wears
hijab some who have even stooped to such
an evil low level plotting to bring harm
to a Muslim woman in hijab as we've seen
a manifestation of that hate in violence
in recent times look at these women and
then go type in Mary the mother of Jesus
and Google search tell me what you see
you see her in hijab that modest non
revealing her body apparel now if you
were to ask a Christian why are these
women that you're watching in this video
these Christian nuns why are these
Christian nuns dressed this way in
modesty it's the same way a Muslim woman
in hijab the answer would be because
they are the best of our women who have
dedicated their lives to God and
everyone can respect it in Mayer that is
something very noble honorable and
righteous we can agree right but a
Muslim woman who wears hijab is
basically doing the same exact thing
dedicating her life to the love and
pleasure of God Almighty
so why the double standards why the
hypocrisy it's very embarrassing I'm
telling you it's very embarrassing and
hypocritical when you see people
hate-filled media personalities
politicians and Sally's preachers who
make fun of bully attack innocent Muslim
women you know women should cover
themselves up like they look like Jabba
the Hutt or what is it was it Boba Fett
whichever one whatever it is please
direct your hate mail to Joe Rogan but
it's exactly the same in their own book
hijab is in the Bible
look it's right in front of you open
your eyes most importantly open your
heart door themselves and modest what is
so modest about this open your hearts
you're watching the best of the
Christian woman right here in this video
wearing the same exact thing Muslim
woman wear this is the hijab in front of
you I want you to remember this the next
time you see a Muslim woman any job
who's following the example of Mary the
mother of Jesus observing the highest
level of modesty and morality dedicating
her life to the Almighty to the creator
Allah you have to have nothing but
tremendous respect to all the woman who
wear the hijab practicing modesty this
modest lifestyle inwardly and outwardly
with modest clothing that resembles Mary
the mother of Jesus and not imitating
the Kardashians Beyonce Katy Perry Mary
Miley Cyrus and the rest of them with
let it all out freak show especially
with all of the ignorant people out
there the hot weather the societal
pressures the sexualization of women
making them feel not worthy enough or
making them feel ugly if they don't copy
the others who are walking half dressed
or hack half naked out there selling
themselves and their souls turning
themselves into slaves of fashion
desires and a corrupt industry making
them fake much respect to the women have
a job who respect themselves and most of
all who love their Creator more than any
of these superficial fake things may God
Almighty
may the Creator Allah reward all of you
with Jenna and grant you the best in
this life and the best in the hereafter
and guide all of those who are sincerely
seeking the creator's guidance thank you
peace what's wrong with it what's wrong
with it how in the world you speak for a
man the comic shush and think about
Jesus are you looking like a stripper to
me
Bible says let the women that women
adorn themselves in modest apparel
modest modest respectable presentable